[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK SAAB: So I'm just
going to start this off
just with a general question
that kind of brings all of us
together and why we're all here.
All of you as artists utilize
technology in different ways,
whether it's social media to
get the word out about your art,
whether it's distribution of
what you create, so can you
just touch upon, as an
artist, why is it important
for you to utilize technology?
And we can start with Yetunde
and move down this way.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Sure.
I think one of the
primary ways, and I'm
sure of all of us agree, is
to be able to get the word out
about what you're doing.
And also, on a deeper level,
to be able to connect to people
who are doing similar things.
I think in my
practice, personally,
I think moving
away from utilizing
social media and
technology only as a means
to market yourself is something
that I'm expanding upon.
So trying to ask questions that
most people wouldn't see online
often.
So a project that I recently
worked on and finished up
is asking 100 questions that
are really intentional questions
like, do you believe
in life after death?
Is there a deeper reason why
you're using this platform?
And it's called "I
want to know you"
and it's an Instagram
specific project.
And I think it goes against
what I feel like a lot of people
use it for, which is a
real reason to utilize it,
but specifically for talking
about what you're working on.
So yeah, I think
that's important,
to not only utilize it as a way
to talk about what you're doing
but also expand upon it
and be able to use it
in different interesting ways.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: I concur.
I think that's the
number one thing,
is to get your projects
or your ideas out,
definitely through
social networking.
That's what it's called, right?
Social networking.
So that's what you do.
And being a part of growing
up with the changes,
a lot of the young
kids is innovative.
And it's like things can go
viral in a matter of seconds.
I didn't know nothing
about "Bird Box."
I didn't have a clue.
And it literally just
took over my whole life.
And I knew when it came out
I was going to be tuned in,
so those examples of just--
you just have to
utilize it and come up
with a plan within yourself.
For me, that's what I did.
I came up with a plan
within myself and my team
and said, look, if
we want to get things
out the way we want
them out, let's put out
the way we want to be put out.
And that's a
platform to do that.
So it was very helpful.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah, I mean, they
all hit the nail on the head.
I think in addition
to that, just
the ability to create
without a gatekeeper
is kind of a new thing
enabled by technology.
No one in my family
comes from music.
And there's always
a saying, you've
got to know somebody in
music to get into music.
But I won't say technology has
opened those gates completely,
but it's definitely put a
couple back doors in there.
And the fact that I
don't have to wait
until I can get into a
million dollar studio
to get quality equipment, that's
an interface, a microphone,
and a quiet space,
and you can make
a hit that catapults your life.
And music was just
the first to feel it,
but all of these
other industries
are starting to feel those
shifts where it's not just
that, oh, you had a lot of
money so you had the best
equipment, so we think
your stuff is the best.
It's like now, you actually
have to provide ideas.
And now that that
barrier is coming down,
the people with the ideas,
or usually art people,
are finally seeing
the shifts in it.
And hopefully we can get some
of the value out of it as well.
MARK SAAB: Even with
that, going off that,
do you think that
there is anything
right now that makes black
creativity in this space
unique, from your perspective?
So whether it's art,
whether it's filmmaking,
or whether it's music, inventing
games, is there a certain--
are black artists
doing anything that
feels different or even
different from the way
that we've operated in the past?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: I
mean, having a shared
experience of
being black I think
is a really unique thing, right?
That's something that
crosses that-- doesn't
exist within borders
or within any sort
of socioeconomic status.
It has to do with just how you
are perceived by the world.
And so I think that is a
really unique experience,
being able to walk through
life knowing that somebody has
a similar, obviously
not the same,
but a similar experience as you.
And I think that
that is something
that's really amazing.
And that if it is unique, it
has to do with the ability
to tap into that in some
capacity, if that make sense.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Yeah,
it definitely makes sense.
I think-- coming from
the inner city for me,
I think that Richmond
taught me a lot
about these type of things.
But I would say being
black is something
that you can't escape.
So it's like when
you create something
it's not about being the best
black thing I can create.
It's about being the
best thing I can create,
and that just comes with that
territory because I'm black.
And I think that creating
things with people
of different
backgrounds, for me,
was mind blowing and just dope.
I mean, we all come from
different walks of life,
but we can create
something in art.
And I feel like whenever
we create anything,
I think all of us want
to make something that's
thought provoking, where
you can-- it's timeless,
it can last forever.
And it's not afraid to
fail within doing that.
And I think that's what can
get you to that next level.
FUZE THE MC: And I
think also the diversity
within what it means to be a
black creative innately makes
it unique.
Because we have traditionally
not had access to these tools.
For some of these tools that
other cultures have been using
since the '60s and '70s in a
very, very major way, a lot
of those we're just now getting
into, and just now exploring
what it means for us.
So like you said,
black people come
from all shades, all countries,
all religions, dialects,
languages, all of
these different things.
And the only thing that--
not the only thing, but
some of the only things
that bind them together
is this shared experience.
So in that case, it's kind of
unique from any other culture
because by its nature
it's super diverse.
And I think we're
finally starting
to see the more diverse
aspects of the perspective
rather than this narrow
focused view behind what
the gatekeepers
saw in our culture.
Now it's like, no, let me tell
you what's actually going on.
Because there's actually people
who invent things, and make
movies, and do social
experiments, and you
really wouldn't even know that
unless you're deeply in it.
It's not something that can
be observed from the outside.
So I think those stories coming
to life are really unique,
and I think there's a
lot of opportunity there.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU:
Well, black people
have been doing that for--
we've been doing that forever.
Like, we've been doing
that forever and having
really unique stories and diving
into this multiple dimensional
way of existing.
And I guess I would
question, what do you
mean by having access to certain
technologies or certain things?
Because I feel like--
I think of Sun Ra,
I think of people
who have been doing
experimental films and music
and being eccentric
and not being
this monolithic version of
blackness for a long time,
right?
So-- yeah.
FUZE THE MC: To answer that,
I was saying more specifically
on quality levels.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: OK.
FUZE THE MC: I
think the content,
and the ideas,
and the creatives,
have always been there.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
FUZE THE MC: But it was like--
I mean, and this is
for me personally.
It felt like there
was a span where
we had the golden
age of black film,
and then after that,
the quality level just
went off a cliff where it
just turned into reality TV
as the only--
and what I mean by quality,
I mean 4K, Aria cameras,
the things that give
credibility abroad.
And a lot of those things
are coming back now
because people like
the retro views.
But for a very long
time, the stamp
that made a movie
at the movie theater
amazing and the dude
on YouTube not amazing
was not because the
ideas were better.
It was just around execution.
It was like, oh, 3 point
lighting, there was HDMI input.
All these Canon
lenses, the prices
have dropped dramatically.
You can get a 5D
camera that shoots
the same quality as a 1990s
film that used to cost $60,000.
So now that that's
not a barrier,
you can't just say,
oh, it's low quality.
I think it gives a fair
chance for the stories
and the creatives to express
themselves on a real level.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: That's funny.
It's funny because I finished
film school probably 2012.
So I feel like that
was the biggest thing.
Are you a filmmaker or are
you a digital filmmaker?
I'm like, what are
you talking about?
I'm a filmmaker.
Well, you're not-- you're not
actually shooting on film.
No, I'm shooting on
what's accessible
and what's going to be
able-- what I can use.
Now, I think the gatekeeping
thing is a real thing at times.
It was before because--
all right, you have an idea.
OK, now what makes your idea
so separate from this person's
idea?
And man, how does that
idea get manifested?
And it's like,
well, one, I think
that we have to
make sure that we
are shooting for the quality.
Because why are you
doing something just
to do it, just to be doing it?
I want to do it at the highest
level possible, whatever it is.
Even if it's not
going to be good,
it was the highest level
that I had accessibility to.
And I think that when
you're creating something,
that has to be in the
back of your mind.
Do I just want to put
something out real quick?
Or do I want to make sure I
put every single effort that I
had at that time?
And I think that is what
gets you to do the research
and say, what's the difference
between 4K and film?
And what's the
difference between this?
And finding that
information out.
Because I had to go
through that struggle
and then when I
went through it, I
had to make peace
within myself and say,
all right, I'm cool with
making the Arias, and the Reds,
and these 5Ds.
And they do shoot well.
But I always tell somebody
it's the chef in the kitchen,
it's also the shooter.
It's not just a camera.
Don't rely so much
on the camera.
Rely on yourself.
And that's what's
going to make it dope.
FUZE THE MC: For sure.
MARK SAAB: So--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thank you.
Please, please.
And that's to all of y'all.
There were so many
dimensions to that.
That was beautiful.
Actually, I kind of want to
stay on this for a little bit,
because I actually had
this same thought as I was
thinking about this subject.
When I was growing up,
I think it was probably
at the height of this, quote
unquote, "trash television"
that we're talking about.
So "Flavor of Love," "I Love New
York," "Real Chance to Love,"
I can go on.
Obviously, I watched all
of these religiously.
But to be honest, that, for
the lack of a better word,
that was a lot of
the black television
that I was exposed
to, that I had just
being a kid that was sneaking
watching BET and VH1, right?
And so I guess my question
is, now, if you look at it--
and I'm black really
excited for this generation
that we have in the crowd
of high school students
to think about.
What they see on TV are shows
like "Atlanta," "Insecure,"
"Blackish," right?
There's this whole
other gammut that
runs from everything
to what people
would consider safe to what
people would consider raunchy.
My real question now is, do
you think this is a trend,
or is this going to be the
future of black creativity,
especially as it involves
mainstream television?
So Diaunte, you can
answer that first, being
our filmmaker expertise here.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: I don't
know about all that,
but I would say this.
I was very against
reality TV as somebody
that started off from 7
years ago acting, going
to acting schools, learning,
putting on that grit and grind,
and I'm like, yo,
I did all this.
And now it's just
like, yo, it's a boom
and you don't have to act.
I'm like, wait a minute.
What are you talking about?
So I battled that for a while.
But then I had to
realize something
and I want everybody
to take this.
There's room for everything,
including nonsense.
Because what's your cup
of tea might not be mine.
And that's OK.
We live in a diverse,
innovative world now.
It took me a while to
understand that growing up.
If you want to watch your "Love
& Hip Hops," hey, I might not.
But that's your thing.
That's what drives you.
But I'm always going to ask why.
But don't just disclude
the scripted television,
because a lot of hard
work went into that.
It's a lot of rehearsals,
it's a lot of--
the way things--
I'm going to give an example.
The "Black Panther"
craze was amazing.
Ryan Coogler and I
are great friends.
And the thing about it is--
a lot of people
don't know this--
is that when you have
a gift or something,
I think your gift will
make room for you.
Because he was a
football player.
A lot of people don't know that.
So now he's starting to
use his creative mind
to write his ideas out.
And when you watch on
screen, it started with him
just in his room writing.
So does that mean that people
not tuned into "Love & Hip Hop"
whether it's Miami or--
I don't know where they at now.
But I'm saying it doesn't mean
they're not tuned into that.
But definitely,
those same people
came out to go see
that movie as well,
and everything in between.
So definitely, I think
that it's all great.
It's just about
how you consume it
and what you want it to consume.
So that's from my perspective.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah,
I agree with you.
I mean, we have the discussion
in music all the time.
It's the same thing.
But I think the problem comes
when there's no balance, when
it's like you're
flicking through all
these black channels
and all these networks,
and it's like the sa--
and not even to not
reality, TV the whole genre.
Because I think there are
some interesting things
that have been and
can be done there.
But I'm saying
specifically, put to people
who are not going to get along
and let's watch what happens.
And I think that it
can be entertaining.
I've caught myself
pulled into the drama.
So I can see the value in it.
But I think of it more
like candy in that sense.
It's like, oh, it was great.
It felt good.
But then how did you
feel, really, afterwards?
How do you feel about yourself
seeing the people on there?
What does it do for
your mental psyche
and what you see about
yourself in the future?
And I think a lot of people
just write it off as, oh, it's
just entertainment.
I think that's a
degree, but if you
watch anything for
10 hours a week,
it has some effect on you.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
FUZE THE MC: And that's
consuming any media.
So I think it's just
like any other diet,
you have to pick and choose.
And I think to
use that metaphor,
we used that food deserts.
But now we have platforms
that can financially
hold that kind of content.
Because in their defense,
TV has a very strict way
it makes money.
So the way it makes
money is by eyeballs.
And if they see the
numbers going up,
it's like, oh, OK,
well, people will binge
watch nonsense for 10 hours.
So as long as we can put
ads between that, it's good.
When you have different
business models like YouTube,
and Netflix, and
HBO, who I would
say have different ways of
extracting that revenue,
it creates more opportunities.
So I don't think it's a fad.
I just hope that the
creators in this new system
will find the
leverage and footing
that we never quite really
got under the old system.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: True.
FUZE THE MC:
Because I don't want
it to be a scenario
where it's like,
yeah, that was super dope.
We're going to give
you two seasons
and then we're cutting that out.
And I've seen a
lot of that, where
it's, like, build up
on the buzz of having
this huge all black cast and
get everyone super excited,
they get the social earned
media from all of our stuff,
and then as soon as that
dies down it's like, well,
it wasn't doing exactly
what it was doing
when it came so let's
just pull the plug
and try something else.
Whereas I see some other
shows get a lot more leniency.
So I think it's still about
finding some kind of ownership
and control.
I don't mean necessarily
financial ownership,
but at least the leverage
to be able to say,
no, I wanted this film with this
character playing in this role,
and this is why I
wanted it that way.
So do this.
And as long as people
have their production
budgets held over their head,
that's used as leverage.
I don't necessarily know
if it can be sustained.
I hope so.
MARK SAAB: Yeah, for sure.
And I would love for you to
address this question, too.
And if you could also
address it from the stance
of this huge explosion in
interest in black art recently,
especially since the whole
Kerry James Marshall historic--
all of that.
So can you touch upon that as
well and from your perspective,
how this really massive surge
and interest in black art
from a lot of new people--
what do you think about that
and how that impacts you?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Sure.
I think going into it,
and this whole situation
with a form of
criticality, being
critical of what is being
consumed, is necessary.
I think a lot of what I'm
seeing right now in black art
is really exciting.
I think a lot of
people are sifting
through a lot of black
trauma almost, and wanting
to sift through
that in a way that's
respectful to all different
kinds of black people.
The problem that-- not problem,
but the worry that I have is
that it almost seems like--
I'm sorry to use this word
in front of high schoolers,
but it seems like
black trauma porn.
It seems like a lot of--
I worry that a lot of curators
and a lot of these historically
white institutions are
consuming black art
in a way that is
consistently having
it be in relationship to white
supremacy and black pain.
And I think moments where
I find more exciting
are these moments where
people are taking media--
film I'm thinking of "Random
Acts of Flyness"-- yeah,
which is a really
interesting, and dynamic,
and non-linear form of
storytelling, and filmmaking,
and video making, that I
think does not put black pain
and white supremacy at the
center and focal point of its
narrative.
And I think that
that is often even
having to do with reality TV.
I mean, why is that
so popular, right?
I think that that has a lot to
do with witnessing black pain
and struggle.
And so again, it's entertaining.
I will not lie.
I am watching "Love &
Hip Hop: Miami" right now
and I'm waiting for the
episode to come out.
But also, I consume that in a
way where I'm saying, OK, cool.
This is something
that I'm not going
to let anybody tell me
defines black people in mass.
I'm going to make sure that
when I watch that, I'm like, OK,
I'm watching this critically.
VH1 is making a lot of
money off of this series.
They've been doing it
for a very long time.
And I think it's all
about having balance.
I think it's all about
recognizing the power dynamic
and structures within
these institutions.
And I think that applies for
film and music and art as well.
MARK SAAB: Thank you.
So I want to stay
with this conversation
because what you just said
makes such great points.
And I think an example of
the exact opposite of what
we'll call trauma porn, I
love that term actually,
is your exhibition
which has just opened--
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
MARK SAAB: --at SOMArts.
So congratulations on that.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Thank you.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Congratulations.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Thank you.
MARK SAAB: Yes, yes.
So your exhibition,
"Forever, a Moment:
Black Meditations on Time and
Space" can you get into that?
Can you kind of just talk about
the title and what that means?
And how do black identities
think about time and space?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU:
Yeah, definitely.
So "Forever, a Moment: Black
Meditations on Time and Space"
is a show of 13 black artists.
It's at SOMArts which
is in San Francisco.
And it's part of the
curatorial residency where
they bring on
curators, or people
who aren't curators who want
to curate, into the space.
It's a really big space,
like 3,000 plus square feet.
And the whole premise and
decision making with me
and my co-curator,
Kevin Daye, was
to put black experience
and collective black memory
at the forefront of
the gallery experience.
So a lot of times, like I was
saying, black pain and trauma
is often the focal point
of a lot of artwork
that I'm seeing right now in
a lot of curatorial decisions,
which is disappointing.
And what we decided
to do is we decided
to make sure that
expanding on blackness
and making sure that it's not
associated with a monolith,
like some sort of weird
black canon where it's always
about our relationship
to whiteness,
which is not the case.
We're so much more.
We're expansive.
We've been here for forever.
We're always making.
And so really trying to put
that resiliency and innovation
into the gallery space--
and thinking about
how oftentimes,
when you're going
into a gallery,
you're just there
to consume the work.
And you're not actually
engaging with the work
and having to think about it
critically, step over it, get
into it, make yourself smaller
or make yourself larger
within the space.
And so thinking about non-linear
time and thinking about how we
experience black art--
so we spent a lot of time
thinking about the layout.
Almost nothing is on the walls,
which is really different.
I'm sure with gallery people you
know this is really different.
And also making a
living-- the thing
that I really enjoy the most
about the "Forever a Moment"
space is we have a living
room space in the back
that has Kevin and I's family
photos, a lot of books,
and media, and blackazines,
which I think a lot of people
don't think a lot about of how
our experiences are actually
archived and how they're
living beyond us.
And that's what I think is
super interesting about music
and film and how
they intersect, is
that it is an archiving tool.
It is how we are
going to be perceived
for future generations
longer down the line.
And that's why I think cultural
production for black people
is so important and making
sure that all the stories are
included, as many
stories as possible
are included in the canon.
Because I think it
does us justice.
MARK SAAB: Definitely.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU:
Yeah, anyways--
[APPLAUSE]
MARK SAAB: So Lance,
so I really want
to ask you this whole idea
of being a game inventor.
And why is it important to
you that a game inventor
comes from the culture?
And along with
that, can you also
tell me some of your
future plans for the game
and how you plan to utilize
technology with what
you've already created?
FUZE THE MC: Yeah, for sure.
I think for the culture,
every title is important.
I think the fact that black
game inventor is not a norm.
It's part of the problem, right?
Because there's lots of black
people, all people love games,
so it's just a
natural occurrence.
And it goes back to the fact
that a lot of our perspectives
haven't been shown yet.
And there's a mass
saturation of everything else
to the point where we're
forced to consume even
our own content and stories
through the lens of people
who are not necessarily
in our culture.
And what that leads to
is one of two things.
Either a great
story that is skewed
through a weird lens, or
it's like a terrible story
that isn't accurate at all.
And I think there are
exceptions to that rule, where
things have married up
nicely, but they're usually
the exception.
I mean, even with
Fortnite, and then putting
all the dances in
the video game,
I honestly don't think
that was malicious.
I think it was just--
there's that far of a disconnect
between the person who
created that dance and the
person who did the mo cap
and put it in there, that
it wasn't even a thought.
And those kinds of presences are
the only way those things even
get brought up.
I think a lot of this
is really systematic.
And to be fair, for a lot
of the game companies,
it's a new, weird thing.
Kevin Durant is a 6'7" person
who plays from all over
the field.
I'm sure for coaches
originally, it
was like, put him as a center.
A lot of times these people just
don't know how to engage with--
don't know there are black
game inventors who want
to have their things out there.
So I think that's part of why
our mission at Cool Black Games
is really, really important.
And it's not necessarily
games just for black people,
but just created
from our perspective
and in the hip hop culture.
Because hip hop culture
is black culture,
and it's the biggest culture
in the world right now.
And we're just now
getting the statistics
to back it up with streaming
numbers and all that stuff,
but we've known for a while now.
And that means that someone is
going to fulfill that demand.
And historically,
it hasn't been us.
So I really want to make
sure that we at least have
our hat in the ring
to be considered
for these opportunities, and
grants, and collaborations.
And for the meme
game specifically,
going to that point,
it's about scale.
That's our next point.
We have a really niche loyal
following who loves our game.
We have consistent sales.
We found product
market fit, so now it's
about how we scale it
as humanly possible.
I mean, scale it as fast
And before, we were using--
it's a traditional card game.
But now we've got to be
bringing those experiences
to the internet, and
to your handheld phone,
and to live experiences
through technology.
I wish I could talk
about specifics
on how that's going
to happen, but we
have some pretty cool
rollouts coming out
that we'll make sure to
keep everybody in on.
MARK SAAB: Yeah, thank you.
And so continuing
with Diaunte, can you
touch upon some of
the voids in media
that you're fulfilling,
especially with your role over
at Beastmode Productions?
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Yeah.
We're attacking everything.
That's what we're doing.
We're not-- there's
nothing we can't do.
The word "no" is like a
figment of imagination
at Beastmode Productions.
We have somebody that's, like--
when I came to Marshawn Lynch
to say, look, let's create
a production company,
it wasn't let's figure
out the particulars,
let's see how we're
going to do this.
It was, all right.
The next day, we got
a production company.
And I think that's important,
is to press play on those ideas.
I felt like it was the best
thing to represent our film.
Our first film, coming from
"A Hundred Blocks" was--
it was made for
and by the people.
We didn't have any name actors.
We broke the lines of what
we were saying earlier about,
you've got to have
four names attached
to a project for
that project to sell.
So when they are
looking at things,
they're looking at like,
OK, well, wait a minute.
So you make this movie.
Who do you have in it?
I got Robert Jordan.
Who is that?
He's a wonderful actor.
I cast him.
I cast it--
It's funny man.
It's so funny.
This is a true story.
I was in film school and I
used to watch "Entourage"
all the time, all the time.
And I had actually
said, oh, this is dope.
They're showing you how the
actors' really lifestyle is.
And I said, well, what if
I did that about hip hop,
especially in the Bay Area with
the independent scene of music?
And I said, oh, I'm
going to cast Mo Green.
He's a great actor.
I'm going to cast Daveed
Diggs, who's now blew up.
But he was that
when I casted him.
I just knew he was loud,
he had long, big hair,
and I knew he was the man.
So as we filmed this project,
I said, this is dope.
So as time went by-- that
was almost 7, 8 years ago.
Time went by.
That was my calling card
to get in these rooms.
And I'm looking
for the acceptance
to say, hey, I can do this.
And look how it looks.
It's quality.
Everything's done.
The editing is done right.
And they're still like,
oh yeah, this is cool.
But we need more.
So I was like, what is the
disconnect between my idea
and what you guys want?
But I'm looking at the
actors is blowing up from it.
I'm like, OK.
But then I start to see, with
"A Hundred Blocks" I was like,
well, you know, I'm going to
do everything opposite of what
the status quo was.
And we're going to make this
movie black and white even
though we have the capabilities
to make it in color.
Yeah, we're going to have all
the cast members be local.
Yeah, I'll be holding
them to a high standard.
I did make them do
a lot of rehearsals,
a lot of things,
but I was challenging
who they already were.
I was like, you can do this.
And when they start
to understand that,
and we made this film,
for us to win a grand jury
award in Oakland was big
because I remember Jay-Z saying,
if you can make it in the Bay
Area with any type of art,
music, whatever, oh, you're
good everywhere else.
I didn't understand that
because they're the first ones
to go and say, this is wack.
This is wack.
So that's what we thrived on.
We don't have any limitations.
We did do it in a variety space.
So we did add a touch
into the reality world,
but we did it in our way.
We wanted to show you
our reality of what
we would do hanging out.
We didn't want to put it
on this type of standards.
We got kids around us on a day
to day basis that are always
looking for the
next thing that's
going to help them be better.
So that's why I'm like,
we don't have no rules.
We don't have no rules.
The only rule we have is to see
it through, and be creative,
and be the best you you
can be in that project.
We're good with it.
MARK SAAB: Yeah.
So all of you have
really touched
on this idea of
challenging the status quo
and breaking the mold
of what's expected.
Can you touch upon where
that comes from for you
and where that attitude comes?
Is it someone in your family who
inspired you to be like that?
Is there an artist
that you just look up
to that really made
you say, OK, yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] what I want to do.
So yeah, can we start over here?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: How are
y'all going to answer this?
I mean, I don't--
I think people--
MARK SAAB: Is it in you?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU:
--it just happens.
I'm sure-- I mean, we all might
have people that would really
inspire us and push us.
And I could list
the many people who
have encouraged me to
do more and push myself,
but I think it just has to--
it's a decision you make.
It's a decision
you make that you
want to be critical and
self aware of what you can
do and push yourself to
make things that are better
or to help somebody else make
things, or be creative, or find
their voice, or be able
to express in a way
that they haven't
been able to before.
And I think it comes--
for me personally, it
comes from a desire to
be able to free myself
from any sort of societal
pressure or obligations.
And I think that that's
a form of liberation,
especially for black people.
So being able to instill
that within myself,
being able to see that
within other people,
and being able to
support anybody
I can to free
themselves from that
and liberate themselves in
that way, I think, is powerful.
And that's the driving
force behind any of that.
FUZE THE MC: I
mean, to your point,
status quo is in itself
inauthentic because people
are not one thing.
So whenever you're trying to--
especially something
as multifaceted
as art, where the core of it
is that you are expressing
some unique
perspective, for me, I
had a really revelation
moment when I was in college.
I made a song that was really
popular and really trash,
in my opinion.
It was a song that I would have
lots of people sing it back,
and then I would feel
like a terrible person
at the end of it, you know?
And I think that kind of
feeling, a lot of artists,
not just in music,
just art in general,
will tuck it for
the praise, but then
that feeling you get
about yourself when
you get that praise is not the
same as when you do something
you know is authentic,
and creative, and varied.
And then someone loves it.
But then you feel like,
oh, this person really--
it's almost like they love me.
You know what I mean?
But if it's something
that's like a bastardization
of something that came out
of you, you're just like, oh,
but that's-- you like that
thing, but that's not me.
So it creates this
weird dynamic.
And for me, I'll say I had--
specifically with Blu.
At the time, Blu had
been a XXL freshman,
which was a really
big deal back then.
You know what I mean?
That was, like, the list.
When you're on that list, you're
like, OK, you're in hip hop.
That was your co-sign.
So I had a lot of respect for
him, and I just did poetry
but I never really
expressed it out
like that because that wasn't
what people looked to me for.
Because I worked computers,
and all that stuff.
And when I rapped for
him, he was like, yo,
this is really dope.
This is really dope.
He sent me a beat the next day.
I was still in high
school at this time.
You know what I mean?
To me, he still is in my eyes
one of the best lyricists that
ever done it.
And just getting that--
it probably didn't even
mean anything to him.
I have even kept close
conversation with him,
but that moment where he
just sent me that beat
and he was like, this dude in
XXL sent me a beat for my raps.
I got skills.
And just that little
amount was like, OK,
no matter what anyone else
says, man, Blu sent me a beat,
so y'all can't tell me nothing.
And having those
little things are
super important to keeping
that authenticity when
it gets tough.
Those little moments
you can grab on that
let you know who you
are at the purist times,
before the money's involved,
before the opinions,
and everyone else gets
their hands into it,
how you really feel about it.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: I agree
with a lot that you said.
I mean, honestly, I don't
believe in realistic.
And that's my driving force.
I'm an underdog.
I've always been the underdog.
I'm still-- people's crazy.
Still, people are like, oh,
you do this, you do that.
I'm like, I don't see
myself at that, at times,
being honest and transparent.
But that come from
my background.
I grew up in an inner city.
I grew up in the hood.
I watched people leave
this world in front of me.
So for me, time and realistic
is like two things that are--
been poured into me and
a lot of individuals.
It's no such thing as
realistic in my mind
because all you're saying is
that, yeah, I have an idea,
but somebody told me along
the way I can't do that.
And I feel like if
you listen to that,
you will never get to
your full potential.
You will never--
I don't care who you
are, where you're from,
you don't have to
go with the fad.
Oh, they're making
this type right now,
so you have to do that.
Because then you could
find yourself in a box.
So realistic-- always have
the plan A, never the plan
B. Everything you do in the
plan A. If it is a plan B,
it will take you
there on its own.
You don't have to be like,
well, if this doesn't work out,
you're starting to put these
weird things in your head,
and you start to
question everything.
And that's-- the young
people I see in this room,
it's no limit with this.
It's no limit.
It's no-- you're limitless.
You have a superpower inside
of you that is driving you.
The fact that you woke
up today, you're good.
You got the purpose in you.
And you can't let
any one or anybody--
because who's to tell you
that that idea was never
going to transfer?
But I will say this
to add to your point.
You said make sure--
you said people love me.
You start to feel
like people love me.
If you make something because
you like what somebody else is
doing, you becoming a copy.
And guess what?
They're going to want that from
you every time if it takes off.
If that's not
authentically who you are,
you're literally making a copy.
And guess what?
I know several friends of mine
that does music and everything,
and they're stuck in that box.
They keep wanting this
from me, but I'm really
trying to do this.
Now, I don't want that from
you because that one thing that
was fake popped off, now
you gotta stick to that.
And now you're starting
to find yourself
going through depression
even when the money comes.
I don't move-- I
don't chase the money.
I chase the passion.
The money is just going
to be the principal.
It'll be there.
But I don't-- I don't
chase not one dollar.
I'm going to chase
the fact that I'm
investing in people, the people
that I see right here that
are innovators, the people I
see out here that's innovators.
I'm chasing that.
What's-- what's about you
that makes it differently?
And I'm cool with that.
And if it fails, so what?
Keep going.
MARK SAAB: Fail the way
that you want it to fail.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
It took me 7 years
to make my first
movie with no money.
I did it with no funding, none.
I just communicated, I showed
people my passion, and what
I wanted, and we made it.
And it's out.
You can go and buy that.
It's tangible.
So guess what?
Nobody can't tell me anything.
And nobody can tell you
guys anything as well.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK SAAB: Just because you
just recently talked about it,
Diaunte, and I do want
to know specifically--
because I come from
similar backgrounds
from the east coast.
But I would love to know how
you feel coming from where
you come from in Richmond.
How you feel that that's really
shaped the way that you make
decisions as a filmmaker
but also as an entrepreneur
in your own way as well?
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Be willing to
accept the things that I cannot
change, is the biggest thing.
Because it's hard.
It's a lot of people that
deals with daily struggles.
They got to test every facet
of it, from growing up,
my mom being a functional
drug addict, to my stepdad
being one of the
biggest drug dealers,
and me knowing what I
didn't want from my life.
That was definitely
something I'm like--
but I felt normal.
So when you talked
about trauma--
because all you see-- but you
don't even know it's trauma
because it feels normal to you.
And then you start
to look at it--
you start to normalize
your situation, which
a lot of people that I grew up
with, sometimes you get stuck.
So I think that those traumas,
I was the reason why my mom--
I was the human TV guide.
What's this?
Oh, man, I'm watching
Showtime and HBO as a kid.
Not cartoons always.
So I'm looking at the Joy
Luck Club at 7 years old
and I don't even know
what I'm looking at.
But I know I'm intrigued
on this lifestyle.
So I think for me
as a filmmaker,
it was already embedded in that
purpose because of that trauma.
Because I wanted to escape.
And then when I dealt
with it on my own,
and dealt with that
trauma, and realized
that I was going through
that and admitted that,
I realized like, oh,
man, these stories.
These stories that can get
out, like I said earlier,
is limitless.
So I think that's what shaped
me is my neighborhood--
I wouldn't be nowhere
without Richmond.
Because if I grew
up anywhere else,
I wouldn't have this
perspective on life that
can help the next person up.
And my goal is to help
the next person up.
Period.
MARK SAAB: Yeah.
So this whole process has
been really dope for me
because for all of
you in different ways,
at different parts of my life,
I've been deeply obsessed with
the content that you've created,
without necessarily personally
knowing y'all.
For me, the earliest
one is Lance.
So I was a really big part
of hip hop message boards
and forums when they were
pretty much like what
were the pre-social media,
especially for artists.
And Lance, your work
and the type of stuff
that you were creating
just stood out so much.
And I mean, it stood out
amongst great, great rappers.
I mean, people like Drake
were a part of these forums
that we were a part of
and were active members
in sharing music.
And so with that, I
really just wanted
to ask you to touch
upon the projects
that you do, just being
a digital strategist,
and how being so involved in hip
hop but also at the same time
being a digital native
have kind of got you
to where you are today.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah, for sure.
I mean, my start in
digital strategy,
which I'm pretty sure
was just a made up phrase
when I first started
using it, was
I had no intentions to
be a digital strategist.
I was trying to pitch
my music to a dude named
Brian Calhoun, who at the
time was the chief operating
officer at Good Music.
MARK SAAB: Which is
Kanye's record label.
FUZE THE MC: Which is
So I was like, oh, this
dude works for Kanye.
He's going to sign me.
So he came to our school at
Howard and I gave him a CD.
He's like-- for
those who don't know,
a chief operating officer
does not sign people.
In fact, that's probably
as far away from that
as they could possibly get.
But I didn't know that.
So I gave him a CD and he
actually listened to it.
He was like, oh,
this is really dope.
Who did your design work?
I was like, oh, I did that.
Who did your website?
Like, I did it.
He was like, well, I'm
not going to sign you,
but you want to come
work on this project?
And you want to get a check?
And I was like, yeah.
The first project that I
kind of piggybacked on,
one of the first ones
was like Drake's release
of "Best I Ever Had."
It's not even news now, but
it went straight to iTunes
while negotiations
were still going on.
And I saw the power
from the other side
that, oh, these digital
strategies and ideas
I've been using to
build my own career up
without having
any connections, I
saw really early on
that these are things
that everyone was
going to have to do.
And at the time, he was signed
to a management company called
Hip Hops in 1978, which was
[INAUDIBLE] management company,
I think Jeezy at one time.
I mean, they've managed
some of everybody.
And because there was no
real digital footprint,
it was like me and that
one dude I mentioned
before who gave me a job.
That was it.
So lots of really--
lots of responsibilities you
wouldn't really hand over
to a college student just
kind of fell on my lap
because he was like,
oh, just give it to him.
Because it was kind of
like an afterthought.
You're trying to convince
these millionaires who
are super famous, like,
yeah, you need a blog.
And I'm like, blog?
I'm about to get a Maybach.
So as that shift happened and
people started to realize,
like, oh, everything is
going digital, iTunes,
and all these things,
then those departments
started to like,
yeah, we need digital.
Well, who's the
digital strategist?
And literally it was just like,
well, he's the guy we know.
And that snowballed
to the effect
that I worked with Common,
and Lil Wayne, Jeezy, TI,
The Roots, Jill Scott,
[INAUDIBLE] who's local here.
And for me, that kind
of opened my eyes
to the effects of digital
abroad in everything.
It's not just this thing that I
can spam people my music with.
It's something that non-profits
and companies and all
these other organizations
can use, too.
So yeah, it's-- I forget what
your original question was.
MARK SAAB: No, that was it.
That's so it.
That was it.
How'd you get here?
How'd you do it?
FUZE THE MC: Yeah.
MARK SAAB: So Yetunde,
so along with being
an amazing visual artist
who does everything
from photography to
painting to the video,
you're also a experimental
musician who also scores
a lot of their own videos.
So can you kind of talk
to me about your process
there, and how all of
that comes together?
How do you-- how do you do it?
And how does that happen?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
I don't-- I don't
know this stuff.
I think most of the time
it comes from my desire,
like I was talking about before,
to archive all these stories.
I feel like everybody's
process is really important.
And how we got to where
we're at is really important
to talk about.
And so a lot of where I start
is talking to my family,
talking to my mom and my
grandma, who are both here now,
but were from South Carolina.
We're Gullah Geechee people.
And so there's a
lot about language
and about oral history
that's passed down.
And I don't want to miss it.
I don't want to lose it.
And so a lot of the places I
start is by interviewing my--
just pressing record and
just having a conversation.
And so I don't know, it
feels important as far
as tying it in with what
everybody else is saying
about understanding
where you come from
and being really true
to your authentic story,
and making sure that you
understand where you come from
and what you can
bring to the table.
And also what you
don't want to be.
I feel like just listening
to them talk, especially
with talking about
relationships,
and talking about having to
move, and being displaced,
it feels like stuff
and lessons that I
need to make sure I remember.
So I guess where I
start is just wanting
to make sure I remember
all these things
and making sure that I can
pass that down in some way.
But yeah.
MARK SAAB: That's awesome.
Thank you.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU:
Yeah, no problem.
MARK SAAB: So I want to
get into a portion where,
especially before we
kick it over to Q and A,
I would like to just kind of
know about some stuff that
y'all like.
And so I have specific
questions for each of you.
So for you, Lance, I
want to know what's
your favorite meme right now?
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Oh.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Oh, wow.
FUZE THE MC: My favorite meme.
MARK SAAB: Yeah, yeah.
Or some of them.
If you can't pick one,
two or three is fine.
FUZE THE MC: So one that I
find myself going to a lot
is the Waka Flocka one
where he looks over
and he looks back again.
Because there's so
many scenarios that
are happening right--
especially on the internet
for black people and black
culture where it's just like,
you don't even have-- you
can't even get angry anymore.
It's just-- you just kind
of give it a side eye.
So I find myself going
to that one a lot.
And me knowing who
Waka Flocka is,
he's kind of perceived as
someone who doesn't have
a lot of emotion,
or people think he's
a trapper, all these things.
So to see that nuance of emotion
and response and understanding,
too.
People think Waka's dumb,
but he's not at all.
And a lot of people
from the south
have that thing where it's like,
you hear the accent and then,
oh, he must not be intelligent.
And I don't know, that meme
[INAUDIBLE] a lot that I can
see the--
I get what's going on.
What do you-- you know?
MARK SAAB: Yeah.
FUZE THE MC: I see the plot.
That's the phrase I'm
thinking of in my head.
So that's my favorite
meme right now.
MARK SAAB: I like that.
I like that.
Diaunte, what are some of
your favorite film projects
that are going on right now?
And if there's none right now
that you particularly love,
then I'm just interested
to also just know
what films you really love that
just inspired you to do this.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Films that inspired me.
One film that inspired me--
well, there's two.
Well, "Seven" was my favorite
film because of the--
I didn't know who
the director was.
I found out it
was David Fincher,
but I'm saying it
was just everything
about what he was doing.
Denzel Washington was supposed
to play Brad Pitt role.
He turned it down.
He shouldn't have.
But I wish he would have,
but he turned it down.
But it was still
a phenomenal film.
That inspired me the way I
could think outside the box.
And then there was
a movie called,
when I was in film school,
"Sweet Sweetback's Badass
Song."
MARK SAAB: Oh, yes.
Yes, yes.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
And I was like--
first off, in film
school, you got
to watch, in film
appreciation, movies
that you wouldn't
normally watch.
And I was like, what
did I just watch?
This is crazy.
My film directing teacher was
like, look, we gonna watch it.
And I want you to watch another
movie which was just "Bad Ass."
And I was just like--
it showed how he made
"Sweet Sweetbacks."
And that right there I
appreciate that movie so much.
And that would be
one of my top movies
because of how it was made.
Because he had nothing.
He had nothing.
So that's when that
got introduced, like,
oh, you just got to be
creative and resourceful.
We had a scene in our movie.
The producers came
to me and said, look,
I love this idea that you
have, but check this out.
That scene cost $90,000.
I was like-- so what
am I supposed to do?
They said, you
got to get 90,000,
or you got to be
creative to do it.
And I was just like--
I think it was a home invasion
scene or something like that.
And we had all these--
there's blood coming.
I was like, oh yeah, OK.
OK, I got you.
I sat home in my house and
I was watching that again,
whenever I get stuck.
And I said, oh, I know
what I'm going to do.
You know what?
I'll make the audience work.
I'm just going to--
I'm just going to
film outside the house
and have everybody act
inside and we is not--
we just going to imagine
what was going on.
And then they was like--
in the movie theater,
they were like, man,
that point was so good.
I'm like, man, I got no money.
I was able to be creative.
So that-- I mean, those are
the movies that inspire me.
And I think that the
film projects that I
have going on now are a lot.
I have five projects right
now that we are currently
working with.
We doing two projects with Mark
Wahlberg that is unscripted.
And then we're actually doing--
we're actually doing
a TV show based on--
I want to fucking say
it, but I can say this.
It has something
to do with Marshawn
but it's going to be scripted.
And then we have a
couple of feature films
that we're going to probably
do in Atlanta and in Oakland.
FUZE THE MC: Nice.
MARK SAAB: So many
secret projects.
So Yetunde, I'm going to
make this a little bit harder
for you just because--
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: OK.
MARK SAAB: --you're such--
and for y'all,
anyone who's here,
if y'all have the chance to
come up to the city in San
Francisco, you really should
see this show that Yetunde has
curated.
And also just-- I
mean, Yetunde is
one of the most prolific
and intelligent artists
that are a part of the active
San Francisco art scene today.
I don't think that there's
anyone who's a part of it
or knows anything
about it who isn't
super familiar with Yetunde's
work as a curator or an artist.
Seriously.
And so with that, can
you talk about some
of the artists who are active in
the scene in San Francisco who
you think people should
be doing their Googles on,
paying attention to,
following, et cetera?
Yeah.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
I think Summer Mason.
If we want to talk
about Summer Mason--
just premiered a
video at the show
called "Velvet Rain"
which is I think
the beginning of a
project, but maybe
a complete project,
"Black Zombies,"
which when they told me, I was
just like, I don't know, sis.
I was like, I don't know if I'm
going to put this in the show,
but let me see it.
But it's actually
really brilliant.
OK, so Summer Mason.
I wrote this down and I totally
forgot everybody's name.
Wait a minute.
MARK SAAB: It's all good.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Summer Mason.
I think that Layla's making
interesting work right now.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK SAAB: Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: I
think Christian Johnson.
I'm really interested.
Christian Johnson
was formerly part
of the Black Aesthetic, which
is an all black film collective.
And I think it's a
book that's coming out
called, "My Skin
is Black Upon Me,"
but he's also doing a
film associated with it
that's going to be
screening, actually,
as part of the show on March 7.
So I'm excited about that.
He's a really smart
film curator and critic
and I'm really excited
to see his work actually
be manifested into something.
And then [INAUDIBLE].
I want to talk about
[INAUDIBLE] who's
not a filmmaker but a fantastic
and prolific painter, talking
about how space and
understandings of memory
and home change.
But those are just a few
on the top of my head.
MARK SAAB: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
So all those people
are super important.
You've just gotten they key
to the next popping artist
for the next 4 years.
So I would like to turn
to audience questions
if you all have any.
AUDIENCE: As a filmmaker,
and you're doing everything
independently, for me, well,
for my last short film,
everything they could have
went wrong went wrong.
Yet I still made the best of it.
And sometimes I look at it
and people are like, yo,
this looks good.
But all I see is, it was
supposed to be like this.
You know?
So what do you--
what do you do when--
how do you function when
things don't work out,
like how you were
saying that you
didn't have the money so you
just shot it from outside.
It turned out brilliant.
Turned out better than
you would have thought.
What do you do when
things like that happen?
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Well, first off,
on every single set I've been
on, there's always a fire.
So I put that in head.
There's going to be a fire.
And you got to put it out.
You have to put in your mind--
not saying you're assuming that
something is going to go wrong.
You're trying to, but you've
got to know, that's filmmaking.
So what I would do
more so than not is,
I go back to what I can control.
If I'm prepared like
I'm supposed to be,
and whether it's financial
or just mentally,
am I prepared to
know what I want?
And have options in your
head how these things can go.
And always feel
like, as a director,
you're a problem solver.
You're a problem solver.
If you've got to take 5
minutes, look, y'all, hold on.
I need 5 minutes
just to process.
And get back in the fire.
And what will be will be.
And you have to
be cool with that.
And you're always never going
to be satisfied with your work.
No creator is, on any
level, not just film.
You're like, oh, I
could have did this,
I could have did that.
Don't kill yourself about it.
Just really say, move on.
Next project.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: No problem.
MARK SAAB: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So for
Lance, my question
is, as a digital
strategist what are
a couple of tips
that you could give
to someone to expand their art?
I feel like there's a
lot of good art out there
but it just doesn't
necessarily have the reach?
So how do you--
how would you say are a
couple of ways that you can
expand someone's piece of art?
FUZE THE MC: OK, I'm going
to throw a question back
at you just because I don't want
to give a vague answer that's
not even actionable.
What kind of art?
AUDIENCE: Let's say you're--
I would love to ask
all of you questions,
but let's say you're
a short film maker
and you are trying to utilize
the digital platforms to get
further out there.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah.
And my point asking
that question
is also just kind of to
show my process about it.
Every piece of content, if
it's not even if it's good,
every piece of content,
period, has an audience.
And that audience is a certain
person at a certain time.
So whenever you're thinking
about your project,
you think about, OK,
who are the people who
want to see short films?
Where are they at in their lives
when they're watching them?
Short films don't have the same
homes as a feature film or even
as a periodic series.
It's kind of an easy
law, but I would
look for programs
like apps that are
created by our culture that feed
specifically to those things.
And find out how you can
work with other creatives
and curators in that space.
I think collaboration
is the easiest way
and it can be the most
organic way to make it happen.
Because if you find
someone that you really
love their art in
that space, you're
probably not the only
one, which means that they
have an audience as well.
And not to underestimate what
they call the mere exposure
effect, which is like if someone
sees something four times,
they'll start to appreciate
it even if they don't like it.
That goes for music, content.
And when you have a circle
that's close to you,
or people that are like,
oh, I really like his art
so I want to go make
something with him.
I got a lot of people in
Oakland, he got a lot of people
in Oakland.
And when those two
networks start to overlap,
that's when you really see
the magic that fires it off
in all these other places.
That, or just have a
really huge budget.
And then just buy Facebook
ads or Google Ads.
But yeah, that
would be my advice.
And then to that point, also,
don't be afraid of advertising.
Advertising is
really-- it's kind
of daunting for a lot of people.
And up until recently,
it's actually
been kind of difficult. But
not to shamelessly plug,
Google's ad platform has
gotten tremendously easier
over the last couple of years.
And that's across the board
for all the platforms.
So you take $20 to the bar.
If you're working on something
cool, put $20 into it and say,
I think these kind of
people like my stuff.
Let me just put it
in front of them.
And the beauty of that is
it's real people who give you
real feedback real fast.
And $20 can give you 5,000
impressions to really find out.
And I think that's the
step that a lot of people
miss is they're waiting for
the big, huge, boom release.
And I'm guilty of it as well.
You start to overthink, oh, I
got to get this person here,
I got to get this
person here, and then
we going to roll out
in this, with this,
and then these people
are going to cover it.
And those things are
good, but a lot of times
that just causes the
paradox of choice.
And you're like,
well, my art's good,
but I don't know how
to get it out there.
So I'm just going
to hold onto it.
I think the first thing is
just getting it out there.
She mentioned Summer.
Summer is someone that I
connected with a long time
ago just because I thought she
was making dope art in college.
And now she's on--
doing openings with her.
So it's like, man, those
kind of little connections
might not be anything right now.
But as you start to connect
with more super talented people,
all those people find
footing in other places.
We connected on a message
board almost 10 years ago now.
You know what I mean?
And now we're at Google.
So just don't underestimate
the people who are around you.
And use those networks.
Because 500 people is
actually a lot of people.
You know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks, all of you.
It was really inspirational.
As an educator, could
you make the stay
in school story sound cool?
Because I'm wondering what--
could you talk
about the difference
between what you learned
from going to school
and what you can teach
yourself online these days?
Because I think we're
in this transition point
where a lot of people still
have the hood story of,
I didn't go to school.
I applied my hood knowledge.
And now I'm up here.
And you have a lot of people
saying that, oh, we'll
learn it all on the web.
I don't need to--
I don't need a mentor,
I don't need teachers.
If you just speak to
the role of education
and how that really played out
for you guys I'd appreciate it.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Y'all want to go?
MARK SAAB: I can
go first real quick
and then you can [INAUDIBLE].
I'll just say really quickly,
so I come from educators.
My mother's a teacher,
my sister's a teacher.
And I still taught myself a lot
but I think the building blocks
to know how to even
properly decipher
what knowledge is right for you
comes from the basis of having
some sort of education.
So I think-- and I'll
even stand here and say
I'm totally about independence.
I think you should have a job.
And I don't even believe
in a side hustle.
I think you should
have a business.
I think you should really
have duality at all times.
But even being able
to do that properly
comes from the basics of
having a good education.
Doesn't matter where you are in
the world, what race you are,
what gender you are, everyone
is uplifted by some sort
of formal education.
So I think it's a
part of being a human,
and it's necessary,
just on a base level.
And that's why we have
fake news because people
don't have a respect for
any sort of institution.
So it's a balance, as we've all
talked about in different ways
up here.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Yeah.
I was one that was
like, you know what?
I don't need no degree.
I don't need no school.
After high school, of course,
but I was like nah, I'm cool.
I'm going to do it on my own
and find a different way.
What he just said, oh, it's
another way you can do it.
And it is ways you can do it.
But I find myself
saying that after when
I realized how many things
were essential if I were
to went to school on
certain things, of course
I went to film school
directly, but if I
went to a university of some
sort, I know I would be--
one, it would have been
fast track, way faster.
Two, I feel like that's
what I really feel.
And I feel like, first off,
you learn so much socially
being at a school.
MARK SAAB: Yeah.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: I go
on college campuses now,
and I'm like, why
didn't I go to school?
What was I thinking?
But you don't know it
until it's too late.
And it's like-- well, it's
never too late to go to school.
But I'm saying, for
what I'm trying to do,
I was like, man, look.
I'm already two kids in.
And then looking at my oldest,
my 13-year-old, I look at him
and he's talking about college
applications and stuff now.
And I'm like, this dude
is nowhere near from me.
But he's his mom.
So I'm like, I'm not
thinking that far.
But I was like, I
see the benefits.
And I'm going to college
campuses with him for sports
and I'm like, oh yeah, let's
get these 3.5 and above.
You know what?
You do this, I'm going
to go back to school.
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to go to that.
My friend's going
to USC Film School.
I'm like, nobody told me.
So don't let the fear--
I think a lot of it was me-- and
I start putting that bad fear,
oh, I don't need school.
But I really needed the school.
So don't-- that's to
psych yourself out.
But yeah, I definitely think
school is very important,
period.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah, and to add
on to that, this might not
be very popular, but I
think there is definitely
a shift towards
people not having
as much faith in the
institutions of college
and how much value they give.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars
in school debt a lot of people
go through just to
find out they don't
know what they want to do.
And that's a very
dangerous, very real thing,
that I don't think gets
beat into kid's head
when they're 17, 18
years old, taking
on loans that will affect
their life probably forever,
according to the student
loan debt problem.
But I think education and
the institution of school
are completely separate.
I think school is really
good for cheat codes,
meaning that you're going to be
next to a lot of other people
who are doing amazing
stuff just by nature of it
being a school and a college.
Howard is notorious for--
people don't necessarily always
appreciate the academics of it,
but our track
record in people who
have stepped through
those halls is unmatched.
Diddy dropped out, do
you know what I mean?
And those are the things
that are intangibles,
that are not actually
attached to the book--
because let's be real.
A lot of these books
become outdated in a year.
A lot of teachers
get into situations
where they're teaching so
they're not out in the field
and they lose things.
But as long as you go into
it with the impression
that this is about
my self development
and I'm going to go get the
things that I need out of it
rather than I'm going to
check off these boxes,
take this paper, and wait for
a check from some employer,
I think if you take
that second route,
you're going to be sorely
mistaken, especially in 4 or 5
years from now.
You might be mistaken this year.
So I would say having
a value for education
and being around
intelligent, smart people,
you spoke about mentors, you
don't have to go to college
to get those things.
I think if you have a really
affordable option to do it,
it's an easy way to get those
cheat codes, get those plugs,
to get--
I met Brian Calhoun because he
came for a panel at my school.
He wasn't going to come to my
house and do a panel, right?
And I wouldn't have
found out about it
unless I was in that network.
And even now, especially 4 or 5
years after you get out of it,
you really start to see, oh,
I need a job at this place.
This dude who I had that
one class with in economics,
he's now the hiring
manager for that position.
And he's not even going to look
at my resume when I come in.
And seeing that in person, that
I've been out of college for--
I'm not going to date
myself, but some years now,
and I haven't had my actual
transcript pulled ever.
And I've held positions at
some of the highest companies
with the biggest artists.
But what really stands out
is your ability to execute,
and your reputation,
and your connections.
And your ability
to execute school
can kind of help with,
but your reputation
and your connections,
if you go to Stanford,
you're plugged, period.
You can't help but be plugged
because of the filtering
mechanism.
So I would say don't
think too much about--
man, I'm reading this book.
I know this trigonometry
isn't going to mean anything
to me in 6 months.
Because you might be right.
But it's not about that.
It's about the
kid next you who's
getting an A in
trigonometry and knows
that the back of his hand.
He's going to be
changing the world.
So you want to be next to him.
You want to build those.
And you want to get some of
that energy off of those people.
That was long-winded, but--
AUDIENCE: How are
you guys doing?
My name is Brian Shea.
I'm one of the chaperones
from [INAUDIBLE] High School.
And I just love what you
guys are talking about.
This is such an awesome
segue because I have students
and some of them
are a little shy.
And Diaunte, especially you were
familiar with Marshawn Lynch.
You know, [INAUDIBLE]
football, he's
been up there a couple of times.
But even for Yetunde and Lance,
I hope I said that right,
do you guys have a
process for mentorship?
Do you have a process for
internship or externships?
How could the students
get access to you?
And even if you don't
do that, how could they
get in contact with you online?
Or what's your social media
handle, just so that they
can follow you and
get a little bit more
familiar with who you are
and what you're doing?
We're super, super
interested, though,
in the Beastmode connect because
we have a whole multimedia Best
Buy teen tech center.
And I'm telling you,
some of the students
are already making
their own films.
Some of them have
already won awards.
And these are kids who--
I love the conversation we
were having about education
because I think, as Yetunde
was talking about trauma as it
relates to white supremacy
or the oppression
or systemic oppression,
education in itself
is embedded in that.
So as we start to talk about
learning and different learning
modalities, it's
not going to work
for kids who are coming
from vulnerable communities.
So if we, as artists,
or the black artists who
are making the next wave are
not keeping that in mind,
a lot of kids are marginalized
but they won't ever
get to where you are
just because of where
they were born, period.
So yeah.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
MARK SAAB: Thank you.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Wow, that was a lot.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah, I know.
AUDIENCE: The question.
The question, the question.
How do they get in
contact with you?
How could the internship-- we
are looking for the connect.
What's the connect for them?
The plug.
That's the real question.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Yeah.
MARK SAAB: Thank you, thank you.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: I mean,
if anybody is out there
and wants to learn
about being in arts,
wants to learn about being an
artist, my door is always open.
I have a lot of connects
through MoAD's, Museum
of the African Diaspora, San
Francisco Museum of Modern Art,
[INAUDIBLE] Center for the
Arts, I've worked there.
If anybody-- if you want
to be a curator, which
is showing people's
artwork, if you
like making experimental
videos, I can help with that.
I'm also getting my
master's at Mills College,
so if you are interested
in Mills College, which
is a really good
school and they have
different kinds of programs.
A lot of people I
know have gone there.
Anytime.
If anybody wants
to come up to me,
I will share my
number and my email.
I also work at a organization
called Counter Pulse, which
is an organization that
does a lot of dance
and experimental dance.
So if you're a dancer,
if you need studio space,
rehearsal space, let me know.
Let me know.
Anything you need.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON:
Same way for me.
That's what it's all about.
That's why I'm here
right now right.
So it's like-- it is a
tricky business, you know?
I know I get busy at
times, but I don't ever
want to get too
busy to the point
where we can't have a
conversation to get you
where you need to go.
I'm very accessible
whether if it's meeting
you guys after the thing.
You can get all my information
far as what we got going on.
And we're going
to have a lot of--
the Beastmode Productions
is an umbrella extension
of a lot of other things.
We have Family First.
Family is the foundation.
And a lot of kids wants to be--
we did Beast of a Business.
And you have an
idea for a business,
and you could have applied and
helped get through Shopify,
get your business off the
ground as a high school person.
Architecture.
We have-- it's not just film.
It's everything.
And the foundation-- we have
a West Oakland youth center.
We have classes throughout
the summer, everything.
So it's a lot of things
that we're actively
in the community day to day.
We're not just too far off
doing these great projects.
It started with just being right
here on a day to day basis,
being on the ground.
So yeah, and to even
go into another step
further is that just
make sure you guys are--
literally, you might
have heard it--
your future.
And I think that
if you hear, you're
like, oh, OK, that's school.
I'm the future.
No, you're the future.
I don't know-- it's
somebody in this room that's
going to be the next best film
director, the next best music
artist, everything.
It's somebody in this room.
And it's crazy because it's
a couple of years away,
or it could be
happening this year.
There's no age
limit to greatness.
So I just think that--
if any way--
I'm sure, if any
way we can help--
we wouldn't be here if
we wouldn't want to help.
But help-- remember this.
Help doesn't mean
I'm doing it for you.
Help means I want to help
you understand what you have
so you could plant that seed
so you could let it grow.
Because once you
watch it grow, you're
going to do everything
to protect it from dying.
And that's what I can give.
FUZE THE MC: [INAUDIBLE] I mean,
I'll echo the same sentiments.
Just hit us up.
I mean, we're live streaming,
so I want to put it out.
But if you come up
to me, I'm open.
I have lots of connections that
are not even relevant to what
we're talking about here
but that could plug you
in lots of different ways.
And I'll say in general,
this is like a really open,
friendly environment because we
have common ground and space.
But going forward,
when I was young,
I used to think, like,
man, I'm only 16.
They're not going
to care, da, da, da.
Trust me.
It is a perk right now that
you only have four window.
Right now, if you just
email someone and say, yo,
I'm 17 and I x,
y, z, it's already
perking the interest
of people like us
because we see how early that
these desires are being--
and that's when you need
to start them to make
them become something great.
So don't be afraid--
like yo, I don't
have the answers.
I don't exactly know even what
you really want to ask for yet.
Just start those conversations.
And if you want to
make it real easy,
find a simple way that you
can help the people you're
trying to reach out to.
I'm not saying that has
to be for me or up here,
but you say, hey, look, I really
want to be mentored by you,
and I'm also going to bring
me and 6 of my friends
to my opening.
You know what I mean?
I'm sure she would
appreciate that, right?
And it shows that,
to the other person,
even if it's not something
that's really helpful, that you
respect their time, and
their influence, what
they can do for you.
So yeah, don't be afraid
to use-- like, I'm young,
and we're here.
DIAUNTE THOMPSON: Absolutely.
FUZE THE MC: Yeah.
MARK SAAB: Yeah, well, thank
you everyone, for your time.
This has been an
incredible panel.
And yeah, we're pretty--
yeah.
Yeah, thank you.
YETUNDE OLAGBAJU: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]